bei den ministerpräsidenten gestern ging
es also auch viel um das thema geld
werbezeit was und das thema geld spielt
heute auch eine wichtige rolle im
bundestag wo es genau geht das weiß mein
kollege erhard scherfer
es geht den rasen tatsächlich ums geld
und das gleich zweimal heute vormittag
hier im deutschen bundestag und den
beiden fällen geht es um steuer
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger aber auch in einem großen maß für
die wirtschaft zwei gesetzentwürfe
liegen vor auf der einen seite aus den
koalitionsfraktionen und zwar das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 und 22 da ist
der hintergrund für die hohen
energiepreise die ist ja schon zu beginn
des jahres gegeben hat und dann gibt es
einen gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
und zwar den entwurf für das inzwischen
vierte corona steuer hilfe gesetz und
der hintergrund für dieses entlastung
steckt im namen schon mit drin und da
auch zeit geld ist fangen wir relativ
zügig an mit unserem interview vor der
debatte und ich freue mich dass zum
ersten mal an dieser stelle heute morgen
bei uns sind markus herbrand der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion guten morgen ihn und
christian görke hat hier auch an dieser
stelle seine premiere bei phoenix der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion guten morgen ihnen beiden
am tag nach dem 25 geburtstag von
phoenix ich streue es einfach noch mal
bei dieser vielen dank ich stress
einfach bei dieser gelegenheit nochmal
ein fangen wir mit dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz an herr herbrand
herbrand was wen wollen sie erreichen
und wie groß wird diese entlastung dann
tatsächlich sein damit den mit dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz erreichen wir
die bürgerinnen und bürger insbesondere
jedes jahr darum den grundfreibetrag der
rückwirkend reduziert wird das wirkt
sich vor allem für die einkommen die für
die niedrigeren einkommen aus dass das
ist auch gewünscht so es gibt ja auch
andere
gesetzespakete die in diesem entlastungs
paket drin sind das ist sozial sehr
ausgewogen gemacht worden weil die
wirkungen der inflation aus meiner sicht
und aus unserer sicht natürlich vor
allem diejenigen treffen die nicht ganz
so viel verdienen entlastung der
bezieher von kleineren einkommen herr
görg hat er muss ihnen doch quasi das
herz aufgehen als ich dann natürlich das
herz auf und
vor allen dingen wir sagen wir so die
diese entlassungs gesetze gehen dass wir
in die richtige richtung aber sie sind
aus unserer sicht sozial unausgegoren
und sind auch springt zu kurz nehmen wir
mal die pendlerpauschale ja die wird er
jetzt erhöht ab dem 21 kilometer und es
werden gerade die entlastet die vielfalt
und vor einigen höhere einkommen haben
und insofern kann ich ihnen mal ein
beispiel aus der hauptstadtregion aus
meinem bundesland einfach mal nennen wir
haben 300 tausend pendler und von diesen
plänen der koalition wird ein drittel
nicht profitieren und das ist das was
man hier kritisieren muss und deshalb
sagen wir wir wollen ein
paradigmenwechsel wir wollen ein
mobilitäts geld ein mobilitäts geld das
ab dem ersten kilometer natürlich auch
für die die wenig haben gezahlt werden
wäre die nächste frage gewesen was in
ihrer alternativen ideen sind aber wir
können das jetzt hier mal durch arbeiten
ich habe mir die drei entscheidenden
punkte bei diesem gesetzentwurf ohnehin
raus geschrieben grundfreibetrags
betrachter scheint es keinen großen
distanz zu geben aber
entfernungspauschale sie sagen das
gesamte gesetz das gesamte paket sei
sozial ausgewogen herr görg erhält gehen
vor neu ist das nicht weil es einen
bestimmten teil der bevölkerung
bevorzugt mehr geht immer das kann man
natürlich sagen wir haben uns natürlich
auch vorgenommen in diesem paket die
entfernungspauschale insgesamt in den
nächsten jahren noch einmal zu
überprüfen dahingehend was da gemacht
werden kann ich selber komme auch vom
land bei mir fahren die leute auch
teilweise 70 100 kilometer zur arbeit zu
gehen sie ja eigentlich niemand zwingt
so weit zu fahren also man könnte und
naja man muss aber schon zur arbeit
kommen sie wissen möglicherweise nicht
wo ich herkomme aus der eifel
genau also man muss schon zur arbeit
kommen und insofern ist es schon so dass
die fernpendler zunächst einmal mehr
belastet sind die fern pendlerpauschale
zu erhöhen war ohnehin vorgesehen wir
ziehen diesem zeitpunkt nur vor
er gibt mir recht der kollege es fällt
fallen viele pendler durch das raster
und vor allen dingen die die
möglicherweise wenig steuerzahlen
beziehung überhaupt keine steuern zahlen
müssen die kriegen wir auch keine
kompensationen und insofern hat sich
hier
manchmal sagen hat sich hier die fdp
natürlich gegenüber den grünen und der
spd der spd linke durchgesetzt denn die
wollten und die wollen auch ein
mobilitäts geld und das ist dringend
nötig diese zu sagen sie vielleicht noch
zwei sätze weil es jetzt das zweite mal
angesprochen haben zudem mobilitäts geld
was wäre besser daran als an der in
diesem fall entfernungspauschale für
fernpendler es muss versteuert werden
und jeder bekommt es ab dem ersten
kilometer und bei uns gibt es derzeit
überlegungen dies bei zehn cent
festzumachen und im übrigen wird das
nicht wesentlich teurer als das was
jetzt die koalition hier forschen
herbrand warum ist es keine alternative
aus ihrer sicht oder ist es vielleicht
doch ein es ist möglicherweise eine
alternative wir mussten jetzt sehr sehr
schnell handeln wir wollten die leute
schnell entlasten und das haben wir dann
auch gemacht wir werden wie gesagt uns
diese entfernungspauschale insgesamt
noch mal ansehen und insgesamt meine ich
auch müssen wir schlicht daran arbeiten
dass der öpnv besser wird damit die
menschen halt nicht mehr 70 kilometer
oder 100 kilometer mit dem eigenen pkw
fahren müssen aber dann geht es auch
schon los man klotz tiere beim militär
weil er auf fast 100 milliarden und
anstatt wirklich die gleichen beträge
zur verfügung zu stellen die
verkehrswende zu finanzieren dann
braucht man sich in die büsche und das
geht nicht und ich finde das sind
falsche weichenstellung und ich hätte
das auch nicht erwartet von der fdp
vielleicht von den sozialdemokraten und
den grünen dieser bundestagsfraktion
hätte ich das nicht erwartet
errechnet das sind jetzt sachfremde
erwägungen in meinen augen das muss man
jetzt miteinander in verbindung bringen
wir war und zwar daran gelegen jetzt
entlastungen sehr schnell entlastungen
auf den weg zu bringen das haben wir mit
diesem gesetz gemacht und das tun wir
auch mit dem anderen gesetz worüber wir
noch sprechen werden mit dem corona
steuer hilfe
es gibt ja eine menge päckchen gepackt
worden sind die grund kritik habe ich
gesagt und dann nehmen wir mal dieses
eine päckchen der energie pauschale die
einmalige zeit wird einmalig 300 euro
brutto und netto beträge je nach
steuerklasse zwischen 116 190 euro bei
dieser inflation wird das regelrecht
offiziere und dann für drei für einmalig
und wissen sie was ich kritisiere dass
studenten minijobber abermillionen von
rentner einfach mal vergessen worden
weil sie nicht zu den erwerbstätigen und
auch hier hat sich die fdp und nicht
dass er denke nicht so wie sie dafür
aber eins zu eins durchgesetzt der also
von fortschritts koalition kann ich
wirklich bei diesen entwicklungen
wirklich nicht reden das ist ein weiter
so nur mit anderen farben aber auch ein
anderes gesetz worüber sie jetzt
sprechen das entlastungspaket 2 ja wir
sprechen jetzt über das verfassungspaket
wird das noch kommen wird wir sprechen
jetzt über das entlastungspaket 1 sven
machen das ja in der tat noch aus dem
kabinett glaube ich dreiundzwanzigster
zweiter stand also auch noch gar nicht
mit dem krieg zu tun hat sondern
schlicht und ergreifend diese langen
anhaltenden und sehr hohen
inflationswerte zur grundlage hat da
nehmen wir doch mal dieses andré ist
jetzt was heute auf der tagesordnung ist
so wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht geben
sie mir eine chance wenn auch eine
nachfrage des bestehens mit dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz hier am meisten
profitieren ledige mit hohem einkommen
bestimmt hast habe ich das richtig
gelesen 170 euro im jahr wenn man ein
einkommen von 6500 euro im monat hat
kann das hinkommen da bin ich ehrlich
gesagt da bin ich tatsächlich jetzt über
fragt angesichts der reduzierung des
grundfreibetrages würde ich das in frage
stellen wollen er macht sein also da
würde mich jetzt auch nicht an der
stelle fest länge weil die blöde
trotzdem noch mal diesen einen punkt was
es mit denen die wenig bis gar keine
steuern zahlen dem punkt den herrn
örtlich auch angesprochen hat wie was
nützt der person
in diesem fall dieses
steuerentlastungsgesetz einfach um es zu
verstehen die die sind in anderen
gesetzen berücksichtigt über der
heizkostenzuschuss über den über den
kinder zuschuss für von armut bedrohten
kindern das sind andere gesetzes nicht
um das nicht am steuer untersuchen
ich habe ihnen gesagt sie können
aufeinander eingehen
der rarität der parität der paritätische
wohlfahrtsverband hat gesagt es dass der
regelsatz auf über 650 euro erhöht
werden muss und wir sind jetzt 440 und
dann kommt einmal 200 euro dazu und auch
möglicherweise einmal einen
heizkostenzuschuss dem man auf
parlamentarischem druck auch der auch
der linken in der spd wir haben das auch
unterstützt jetzt nachgesteuert hat das
sind ja punkte in die richtige richtung
aber sie reichen nicht aus um wirklich
diese problemlagen die wir in
deutschland haben endlich mal
sommermeyer abzug hat also die gegen
finanzierungsfrage will ich jetzt nicht
aufbringen dann sprechen wir gleich über
die vermögenssteuer dann kommen wir
gerne habe ich nicht mehr rechtzeitig
hier weg doch das schaffen wir schon
weil er wollte ich sowieso hin weil das
ist ja schon eine zentrale zu
überspringen wenn mal diese corona
steuer hilfe gesetzt und kommt
tatsächlich zu diesem punkt der mich der
finanzierung ich glaube die steuer
mindereinnahmen beim
steuerentlastungsgesetz dass muss jetzt
aber müssen sie erstmal bestätigen sind
ungefähr bei 4,5 milliarden und dem
zusammenhang mit dem mit dem corona
steuer hilfe gesetz liegen wir bei zehn
oder elf milliarden glaube ich sogar
über eine längere strecke wenn ich mich
nicht irre trotzdem wo dieses geld
herkommen
ja wir haben ja der ausstattung der
haushalt ist ja eingebracht und es
wurden die eckwerte eingehalten die noch
von der vorgängerregierung eingebracht
wurden diese eckwerte sind eingehalten
obwohl wir diese zwei entlastungs paket
mit auf den weg gebracht haben es wird
noch einen ergänzungs haushalt geben der
schlicht und ergreifen aber nur mit
dingen zu tun haben darf die die
wirtschaftlichen folgen des krieges
dieses schrecklichen krieges abfedern
also im grunde genommen ist das haus hat
der ish abgebildet aber sie wissen noch
nicht wie es weitergeht weil sie setzen
ja in teilen auch darauf dass
durch indem sie beispielsweise die
wirtschaft entlasten bei dem corona
steuer hilfe gesetzen dass dann die
wirtschaft wieder in deutlicher
anspringt dass menschen steuereinnahmen
dann auch generiert werden und ein
gewisser weise dann auch nur ausgleich
zustande kommt die wirtschaft wird
entlastet da das sehe ich aus aber sind
in der regel fortlaufende dinge es gab
ja auch schon corona steuer für die
selbst eins zwei und drei wir verlängern
die maßnahmen jetzt weil die bei die
pandemie einfach länger ist als als wir
uns das alle denken die finanziellen
auswirkungen sind da nicht so
fürchterlich in der tat gehen wir aber
auch davon aus dass wir ansonsten an
anderer stelle mehr geld aufbringen
müssten also wir versuchen ja da den weg
des geringsten widerstandes sozusagen
ganz kurz vorher aufbringen oder wie
habe steueraufkommen selbstverständlich
okay nicht neue steuern auch keine
steuererhöhungen sowieso eine steuer
erhöhungen und auch keine neuen schulen
christian görke war finanzminister mal
gucken was er dazu sagt in brandenburg
der kollege lindner finanzminister der
fdp jetzt hat allein in den letzten
monaten in der prognose mehr
steuereinnahmen durch die erhöhten
mehrwertsteuer bei den energieträgern ja
schon prognostiziert
25 milliarden euro die on top kommen und
dann hat die europäische kommission und
das ist normal ein punkt den betriebs
ländern der europäischen union auch
deutschland empfohlen diese sogenannten
zufalls gewinne die die
mineralölkonzerne jetzt durch diesen
preisanstieg den sie möglicherweise auch
selbst forciert haben mal abzuschöpfen
und in europa geht man davon aus dass
ungefähr 200 milliarden euro an erlösen
selbst immer nur 50 prozent davon
versteuert erreicht werden kann für
deutschland prognostizieren wir die
finanzexperten nichtig die fachleute
ungefähr zwischen 15 und 20 milliarden
euro mehreinnahmen schon allein mit
diesen beiden maßnahmen kann man diese
pakete aus finanzieren und dann gibt es
natürlich noch andere möglichkeit ich
meine die machen schulden
noch und nöcher und in einer krise muss
man das auch mal aber dass man dafür
dass aufrüstung damit finanziert und
nicht möglicherweise in die wirtschaft
das lenkt das ist das was wir
kritisieren herr brand direkt gerne also
dass der kollege in die wirtschaft
investieren möchte finde ich wunderbar
klar also dass nicht sogar untersagt
wird also wir natürlich dabei die idee
der zufalls steuer findet bei uns keinen
anklang ich glaube das habe ich ja
überhaupt nicht gar nicht richtig
verstanden und mal ganz ehrlich zu sein
irgendwie weil das ja so ein begriff ist
der in der tat ja auch wenn nicht
besonders häufig vorkommt den
finanzpolitischen debatten henry abgriff
über gewinn steuer sagt man auch gerne
schon mal
ganz in sein und sagen so erklären dass
das unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
auch verstehen und ich am besten auch
also nehmen wir die mineralölkonzerne
beispielsweise die möglicherweise in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten dann doch
deutliche über gewinne gemacht haben so
würde der ein oder andere sagen dass die
von diesen gewinnen eventuell mehr
abzugeben haben wir halten das für keine
gute idee sondern dass ein das ist in
unserer aus unserer sicht ein
unzulässiger eingriff in die
marktwirtschaft und archive wäre das
eine andere ist wenn die europäische
kommission hat die mitgliedstaaten
empfiehlt gesetzgeberisch in die
möglichkeit eröffnet gesetzgeberisch
tätig zu werden hätte ich erwartet und
das werden wir natürlich auch als linke
tun im rahmen des parlamentarischen
prozesses dies natürlich als
finanzierung für unsere vorschläge
natürlich mit vorzulegen und wie gesagt
ich bin auch nicht allein wirklich
ökologen teilweise konservative ökonomen
die mittlerweile sagen es reicht jetzt
wir müssen jetzt hier auch mal fair und
gerecht besteuert wir wissen aber auch
dass wir dann einen einhelligen
vorschlag brauchen auf europäischer
ebene der wird es den wird es nicht
geben schon
die kommission den mitgliedstaaten
empfohlen temporär temporär dies zu
machen und in meiner mario draghi ist
nur kein linker noch sind konservativer
regierungschef der hat die eingeführt
und finanziert damit 44 milliarden euro
seines entlastungspaket des in italien
geht doch oder und an dieser stelle
müssen wir mit diesem gespräch hier
aufhören obwohl sie nicht ernähren habe
dass sie sich bei ihrem ersten auftritt
hier bei uns
phoenix oben viertel verein vor einer
plenarsitzung nicht unwohl gefühlt haben
und wir das ganze wie üblich noch eine
viertelstunde länger machen könnten aber
ist kurz vor neun und die
bundestagspräsidentin wird gleich die
sitzung eröffnet deswegen bedanke mich
bei ihnen für ihren ersten auftritt hier
bei uns bei ihnen beiden sehr vielen
dank und wünsche ihnen eine noch muntere
debatte wir sind ja sogar zwei zu diesem
thema wie wir hier zumindest eingerissen
haben danke für heute morgen uns jetzt
dürfen sie auch reingehen und wir meine
damen und herren wir gucken auch in den
plenarsaal reinschauen mal ob